Today's video is sponsored
by Bill and Melinda Gates.
Today, we're doing
an experiment to see
if we can make paper
that's impervious to fire.
[Music]
Guys, we're currently
in the studio,
which is completely covered
with thin strips of paper,
and we've got blowtorches.
Seems like a
terrible idea, right?
So this might seem
incredibly dangerous,
but the paper
that were surrounded by
is actually crepe paper,
and it's actually treated
to be fire resistant.
So while it'll burn,
it's not going to catch fire.
You mean if we start swinging
these blowtorches around,
it's not going to burn
down the whole studio?
Well, we find out.
Some of you may be surprised
to know that paper
can be fireproof.
And as excited as we are to
share this surprises with you,
we've also partnered with Bill
and Melinda Gates to share
with you 9 of their biggest
surprises from 2018.
You can read
about these surprises
in their annual letter,
which we'll talk about in a bit,
but first, let's learn
some more about this paper.
So we can see
that we've got plenty of spots
where it got singed,
it got burned.
But even when you got the
blowtorch concentrated on it,
it doesn't go anywhere.
The fire doesn't spread.
This would be
a horrible fire starter.
Would not work at all,
zero out of ten.
As you can see,
our studio is remarkably
not burned down
despite being lined with paper
and being hit with fire.
So this fire resistance
to paper is
what we're trying to do today.
We're going to take a look
at a few different recipes
of doing this at home,
and see which one
works the best.
Here's the basic idea.
We've got three different
recipes we're going to test
to try and make paper
more fire resistant.
We'll see how they hold up
against the stove, a lighter,
and a blowtorch.
Alright, we've now
seen the commercially
available fire-resistant paper.
Let's clean up a little bit,
and see if we can make our own.
We do have another type of
pre-made heat-resistant paper,
and that's called
parchment paper,
which is usually for baking.
So parchment paper
is treated with silicone,
and that makes it
so that it's slightly
more moisture resistant,
but also fairly heat-resistant.
However, heat-resistant
does not mean
that it is burn resistant.
Parchment paper is designed
to go in ovens,
and while it's great
for things not sticking to it,
and it not burning
up in an oven,
that doesn't mean
it's actually fireproof.
As Calli's just showing you,
it clearly candle lit on fire,
and it actually says
on the box to not touch
it to an open flame.
We've got three
different recipes
that we want to try to make
this fire resistant paper.
The first is what I found
online talking about how you
can use water with some borax
and some boric acid
dissolved into it,
and soak the paper in that.
For our second recipe,
we are going to be doing
basically the same thing,
except we are substituting
our water for methanol.
Methanol is going
to evaporate much faster
than water so our dry times
going to be a lot quicker.
It also won't make
our paper wrinkle.
As a third recipe,
we're using one that's
something Grant has shown you
before quite a while ago.
He showed you how to make
your own rocket wadding.
This is paper
that goes in between the end
of the burning fuel,
and the parachute
before it gets launched out.
You don't want your parachute
to melt or light on fire.
So you use a heat resistant
wadding in between the two
so it will still pop
the parachute out,
but not add too much heat to it.
And what he used for that was
just water and baking soda,
soak the paper in that,
pull it out,
let it dry,
and that created a fire
resistant paper as well.
So we're going to try
all three of these,
and we're going
to see the advantages
and disadvantages of each one.
So for our first recipe,
we have a bowl of hot water.
We've got 4 cups of hot water,
and we're going to add
1/4 cup of borax
and 1/4 cup of boric acid.
[Music]
Stir it all up.
Let it dissolve.
While she's stirring
that one up,
I'm going to get
our methanol version
of the same thing going.
We're not going to have
as much of this.
We're just going to use one
of these little containers,
and we're going to do
about two tablespoons
each of the borax
in the boric acid.
[Music]
All right, here we go.
We've got methanol with borax
and boric acid in it.
So what's fun about this
is you may have seen us
before using methanol
and boric acid
with pretty fun effect.
Green fire.
[Music]
Now, Callie has poured her
solution into this pan already,
and it doesn't mix
into the methanol quite as
well as it does into the water.
So we're just gonna let
this sit, and see
if any of the powder settles
out to the bottom,
and then we'll try and pour it
off the top in the pan.
While we're waiting for that,
we're going to start mixing
up our baking soda as well.
The good thing
about the baking soda is
that you just keep mixing it in,
and once it doesn't
dissolve anymore, any
that didn't dissolve we'll just
settle out of the bottom,
and then you can pour it off.
We've now got
our three pieces of paper,
and they all say
what we're going
to be soaking them in.
So we've got the water
and sodium bicarbonate,
also known as baking soda.
We've got the methanol, borax,
and boric acid going
with the water,
borax and boric acid.
We're going to take one
of these pieces of papers,
and thoroughly soak them,
like really let them absorb
the liquid all the way
through the fibers of the paper,
and we have to take them
out and let them dry.
[Music]
Now, trying to make
fire proof paper
using methanol may seem
a little counterintuitive,
because as we showed,
methanol is flammable,
and with boric acid in it,
it burns green.
While these dry,
let's talk about Bill and
Melinda Gates' annual letter.
Guys, some of you
may be surprised to know
that paper can be fireproof.
But what you may be even
more surprised to know is
that textbooks are actually
becoming obsolete in the US.
Students who are using digital
tools have actually been found
to be getting better grades,
and this is just one
of the 9 surprises
the Gates found in 2018.
We both had our own share
of surprises in 2018.
Calli, what would you say was
your number one 2018 surprise?
I joined a YouTube channel.
Where you not planning
on that ahead of time?
Setting out a New Year's
resolution for 2018?
You know, I think
the application went out
sometime in about March.
At the time,
I was a sculptor,
I was an illustration student.
This came out
of left field,
and I was honored,
and just so excited to be
a part of this channel.
It was amazing.
The guys have been
fantastic to work with,
but no, this blew me away.
This has been a dream come true,
but this was probably one
of the biggest surprises
of my life.
Very cool.
For me surprises in 2018,
especially about the channel,
I have to say I was
super surprised at
what videos did really well,
and what videos
seem to underperform.
Some of the highest
performing videos were things
like putting food
in a vacuum chamber,
and seeing what happens if you
try and melt magnets down,
and they really
took off a lot more
than I was expecting them to.
And some of the ones
that I kind of personally
thought were really cool,
I was like, oh,
this is going to be so great.
They just kind of
didn't go anywhere.
So it's fun to see
what other people are
the most interested in,
and see what
the results are from that.
While we experienced
our own surprises in 2018,
the Gates shared 9 of theirs
in their annual letter.
Head over to GatesLetter.com to
read the surprises they've
encountered in their work,
and how those moments
are prodding them to help
make the world a better place.
I think they're all dry.
I think so.
Taste kind of like baking soda.
Do you regret that?
A little bit.
I regret it for you.
Thanks.
Now, we want to do some tests.
We want to apply heat to these.
I'm thinking a stovetop?
Sounds good.
A lighter.
Yep.
And a blowtorch.
That's my favorite.
All right.
To start off,
we've got a control
piece of paper.
It's just paper.
There's nothing even
printed on it,
and it's not treated
with anything fireproof.
We've got a pretty
hot stove going here.
We're going to see what it does.
Water and baking soda.
Here it goes.
I'm gonna set it on one corner.
Whoa!
That very very
quickly turned dark.
That went so much faster
than the regular paper.
It did.
I'm just curious.
What is it heat different
>> that the stove just heat up?
>> Yeah, it could be.
Stove have already been hotter.
Is that what did it?
Well, it was different.
Oh.
>> Well.
>> It is on fire.
Okay, so the stove wasn't
properly heated the first test,
for our second test,
it was, and this lit
on fire very quickly.
So initially, I thought,
oh, it's doing terrible.
It just burns so fast.
But then, compared to
our properly heated stove test,
that actually did great.
It didn't light on fire.
Water, borax, boric acid.
Here it goes.
Already better.
Charring.
Shrinking weirdly.
That's amazing.
Really not lighting
on fire though.
Not at all.
So even this part
that's like the ember,
that's going way slower
than the other stuff, and we do
not have any flames right here.
Finally, the methanol,
borax and boric acid.
Turning black.
Wow.
Shriveling.
>> And it's on fire.
And it's green.
Let's move on to lighters.
Yes.
Water, borax, boric acid.
1, 2...
6, 7, 8...
10, 11, 12.
I don't think--
I don't think
it's gonna catch on fire.
It's not catching on fire.
So it's burning, obviously,
and it actually seemed
to burn almost the same speed,
maybe a little bit slower,
maybe took like an extra second
before it turned black.
But it didn't catch on fire.
Methanol, borax, and boric acid.
Now, this one, we got to light
on fire with the stove.
We did and it was green.
A little bit
of green flame in there.
1, 2...
6, 7, 8, 10...
I thought I saw
some flame coming off it,
but it--
Oh little.
Tiny tiny bits of flame.
Just little bit.
Just barely catches.
But as soon as the
heat source goes away--
Yep.
Baking soda.
>> That turned black much faster.
>> It's on fire.
It was on fire for a second.
It was on fire for a second,
but then I went out.
So, so far, I would say
that two for two,
our water, borax,
and boric acid
is doing the best.
Well, should we try our torches?
Yeah, we should.
All right.
Blowtorch.
Regularly paper.
This is going
to take a long time.
1, 2--
That's about one second.
Water, borax, and boric acid.
1, 2--
Well...
But it didn't stay.
About the same amount
of time to start burning,
but it's not burning anymore.
That's weird.
Yeah.
Goes right out.
Methanol, boric acid, and borax.
>> That one's staying as a flame.
>> Still on fire.
Yeah.
Still on fire.
It's spreading a little--
Oh, and now, it's out.
Baking soda and water.
Here it goes.
1, 2--
Still on fire.
It's now out.
I think the accelerant is gone.
I don't think there's
any methanol traces left
that's making it burn better.
But I think the water
is doing a better job
of dissolving the two chemicals,
and really getting
them to spread,
and really get into all
of the fibers of the paper.
That's my guess.
I like it.
So our water, borax,
and boric acid is definitely
more flame resistant than any
of the others.
So, can you make
fire resistant paper?
Yes, you can make
fire resistant paper,
and it's not that difficult.
No, most of these supplies
you can find,
the easiest one obviously
will be baking soda and water.
If you really want
the best fire resistance,
then the water, borax,
and boric acid is
your best combination.
That stuff really does not like
to spread a flame.
It acted quite a bit
like the crepe paper.
It really did.
As long as there is
direct heat on it,
it was burning.
But as soon as you
take that off,
it just kind of goes out.
Thanks again to Bill and Melinda Gates
for sponsoring this video,
and sharing their annual
letter with us.
Guys, go to GatesLetter.com,
and learn about more
of the things that they
found surprising about 2018.
Guys, that's not all,
we've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top is going
to take you to our last video,
you should go check that out.
The other box
is going to show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next,
and if you had this bomb
here in the middle,
you'll be subscribe
to our channel so you
don't miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.